new genetic evidence is giving us clues  to the origins of native americans  seven years ago divers exploring  mexico's yucatan peninsula discovered a  dark chamber deep within an underwater  cave  armed with bright lights the divers had  to swim more than a kilometer through a  long tunnel just to reach it  the chamber is so dark that they call it  oyo negro  spanish for black hole  inside the chamber the divers found  large animal bones belonging to sloths  and ancient elephant-like creatures  they also discovered a human skull and a  nearly complete skeleton  the bones belonged to an early ancestor  of today's native americans  a teenage girl who died about 12 or 13  000 years ago it's an exciting find  analysis of the dna from her teeth  supports the theory that native  americans are descended from the  prehistoric people who cross the bering  land bridge 15 000 years ago and not as  some suggest from other source  populations in asia or europe  you